it's guys what does it feel like to be
back in these characters do you feel
confident getting back into their skins
for a season two do you relate to them
in a different way
well seriously uh it feels uh like we're
growing our characters are growing i
know that's a boring answer but you know
we we know the first
the first year we're kind of developing
the character in the second year you're
finding little nuances which one of the
nuances that you found since you weren't
happy with that answer what what answer
would you get well i just would have
given more energy to the i would have
said similar words but i would have had
like a kind of a more energized spending
yeah thank you
what was your question again i don't
know something about revisiting these
characters for another season
it's great
do you relate to to mabel moore this
season um it is in a way but i think
it's also a little bit of of
me actually feeling like
i've walked through those
those moments something in my life so
yeah i've had that winging with it a
little bit which i can swing with your
character a little bit more don't you
want to clear your name too
i have to see this thorough let's focus
i'll be right back hey you can't leave
me here i'm not good at parties you guys
forged this fantastic friendship at
least it seems that way in the first
season how have those those bonds
deepened over the course of the second
season for you
i think it's like anything i think
friendship grows and trust grows and we
have a great happy loose time in the set
and it makes us
love each other more at the end of the
day you know marty and i have known each
other for 35 years but we've only known
each other for two years and i would say
that there's definitely been a you know
growing bonding
thing but a trust between the three of
us we like to do our three threesome
scenes the scenes between the three
absolutely true they're our favorites
how would you guys fare as real life
neighbors do you think these guys would
make good neighbors oh fantastic i don't
know i don't know but this wouldn't be
nice what if you have a lot of parties i
don't know i would i would bring
[Music]
you're the second person to say i don't
know i feel like marty might have loud
parties i would definitely have louder
parties than steve
what are stu it's a steve party i mean
you're you're a musician you're a
musician are we going to get her with
these
oh are we going to get incredible uh the
trio of you guys with the i mean forgive
me the steep canyon rangers no way
why not
we don't we don't we we don't do that we
have our own group yeah
what's the group called it's called the
marty's not my gosh
are we going to get new music from you
yes i'm actually working on it right now
it's just been a little hectic with this
but i'm i am in the studio i'm excited
what are our plans for selena's 30th
birthday
are you really home in bed by the time
you guys aren't throwing you just said
you throw a wild card well i'll just be
getting in when it starts yeah i hope it
happens by 10 a.m so i can celebrate it
[Music]